bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés nous
allons aborder aujourd'hui un sujet
souvent décrié souvent moqué souvent
pointé du doigt pour être la cause de
tous les maux france il s'agit de
l'europe le 9 mai dernier nous fêtions
la journée de l'europe en référence à la
déclaration de robert schuman ancien
ministre des affaires étrangères le 9
mai 1950 un acte fondateur de l'union
européenne depuis le vieux continent a
traversé de nombreuses crises et
notamment ces dernières années avec la
crise en grèce la crise migratoire la
dette
à cela s'ajoute un désintérêt plus
profond pour la chose européens des
citoyens semblent bouder toujours plus
l'europe pourquoi comment et peut-on
inverser la tendance pour tenter de
répondre à cette question quatre invités
avec moi ce soir à mathilde videlo
membres des jeunes européens université
de paris bonsoir
olivier geay nos ex responsable du
centre d'information europe direct dans
les yvelines fait des films rock délais
des délégués de la 2e circonscription
pour debout la france dans les yvelines
et philippe le guen directeur de
l'association jean monnet est basée
également dans les yvelines bonsoir à
vous quatre je le disais en introduction
les citoyens européens et français
particulièrement semblent bouder
l'europe nous sommes presque deux ans
jour pour jour après les élections
européennes l époque près de 58% des
français ne s'étaient pas déplacés pour
aller voter c'est un peu moins dans les
yvelines
c'était 54 % de non votants deux ans
plus tard on imagine facilement que
l'abstention serait sensiblement la même
et qu'est ce qui explique ce désamour on
va commencer par faire un premier tour
de table avec vous delphine rock
probablement la plus eurosceptique ici
ce soir comment on explique selon vous
ce désintérêt pour la chose européenne
parce que je pense que l'europe comme
elle est conçu aujourd'hui ne correspond
pas aux attentes des citoyens de chacun
des pays d'europe qui ne se
reconnaissent pas en elle et et de fait
va ne s'y intéressent pas donc nous nous
sommes plus pour une europe
qui serait une europe des nations où
justement les citoyens se reconnaîtrait
et où on aurait vraiment à coeur de
faire une cohésion des peuples avec leur
culture parce que parce que l'europe
c'est plein de pays avec des des
cultures ancestrales et voilà nous on
préconise plus une europe et peut-être
aussi un petit peu moins là janvier
c'est trop trop importantes tout à fait
qui prend le dessus sur le la
souveraineté des nations deux états tout
à fait c'est ça ça vient se positionner
en amont on le voit bien sûr sur pierre
klein doigt ou maintenant les pays sont
obligés de se référer à l'europe et nous
nous préconisons un libre arbitre de
chaque pays et une plus une association
qu'une obligation de partenariat
mathilde vider l'eau
quel est votre point de vue à vous sur
ce désintérêt pour le sujet européen à
ce que déjà vous partager ce point de
vue selon vous le centre d intérêt et
oui ben on ne peut pas forcément aller
rencontre c'est les chiffres autant
faire un temps de l'abstention des
dernières européennes
au delà des problématiques qui recule
correspondraient pas forcément aux
attentes des des citoyens français ou
européens dans les différents pays aussi
je pense vraiment un manque de
compréhension du fonctionnement européen
on voit ça exactement comme une une
machine très éloignées dont on ne sait
pas exactement comment elle fonctionne
et donc c'est vraiment ce manque
d'information et manque de compréhension
du système à chappes l'on parle de la
commission du parlement de bruxelles
comme quelque chose extrêmement éloignée
et ya enfin il ya vraiment une
une approche pédagogique et enfin rôle
pédagogique à avoir sur sur
l'explication du fonctionnement parce
que on peut pas s'y intéresser si on ne
comprend absolument pas la façon dont on
marche les institutions européennes
manque de compréhension manque de
pédagogie c'est un constat aussi que
vous tirez philippe le web écouter
oui malheureusement la pédagogie devrait
commencer à l'école 1 puisque si on veut
comprendre le monde dans lequel nous
sommes est l espace dans lequel nous
sommes dans chacun des pays membres
c'est aux instituteurs de l'expliquer
des écoles malheureusement le
l'éducation ne fait pas partie des
compétences européennes donc les
instances européennes pense que les
états membres de même son vont faire cet
effort de pédagogie ne le ferons pas
parce que ce n'est pas leur rôle
est ce que les gens ignorent souvent
c'est finalement l'europe n'a pas tant
de compétences qui lui sont déléguées et
que beaucoup de choses sont encore régi
par les états et que les états qui
pourtant décide à 28
quand ils sont réunis à bruxelles ou
ailleurs et bien ne sont pas forcément
ceux qui vont expliquer ensuite leur
décision aux citoyens donc cette
défiance cette incompréhension du
citoyen elle vient de là elle vient des
états qui ne jouent pas le jeu
olivier jeanne rex ou terminer ce
premier tour de table sur ce constat
vous avez du désintérêt pour l'europe
le citoyen tout à fait l'union je pense
qu'on est tous d'accord là-dessus
l'union européenne c'est un schéma qui
compliquait qui est parfois complexe a
expliqué aussi quand on regarde un peu
comment l'union européenne comme unique
notamment tous les documents officiels
c'est tout un jargon qui est technique
faut avoir un traducteur pour avoir un
traducteur pour comprendre tout ça même
vous en tant que dire ce qu'est cialiste
le sujet vous avez vous avez du mal
encore aujourd'hui le fonctionnement des
institutions
alors on va dire que moi j'ai l'habitude
en la matière mais par contre je reçois
c'est souvent dans ma boite mail le
prolé tout ce qui est les textes de loi
les qui vont passer au vote au parlement
ou au conseil de l'union européenne
j'ai pas honte de le dire qu'il ya des
fois je ne comprends pas ce qui est
raconté dans l'est dans les textes parce
que c'est très compliqué c'est une
logique qui est européenne
donc on essaie de faire en sorte qu'ils
aient des textes qu'ils puissent être
compréhensibles par vingt-huit équipes
qu'ils puissent être pris en cible par
tout le monde
le problème c'est que voilà le on a une
10 on a une vraie distorsion entre eux
ce qui entre ce que les gens comprennent
et ce que l'union européenne essaie de
faire passer comme message
alors justement comment une fois qu'on a
dressé ce constat comment on fait pour
rapprocher l'entité européenne du
citoyen vous c'est votre rôle avec la
maison de l'europe les yvelines qu'est
ce que t'es les actions vous mené par
exemple pour essayer de rapprocher le
citoyen de l'europe alors tout
simplement nous on va beaucoup dans les
écoles et on explique comment ça marche
union européenne et on le fait avec des
termes simples et concrets commission
européenne conseil de l'union européenne
conseil européen conseil de l'europe et
compagnie il faut faire la distinction
il faut expliquer ce à quoi ce à quoi
les institutions correspondent et après
il faut il faut aussi leur montrer
concrètement que l'union européenne elle
est là elle est présente elle existe et
qu'elle est là dans notre vie de tous
les jours et que
voilà elle est là une véritable
influence et même s'ils ont ce même si
on ne s'en doute pas mathilde vidéo vous
parliez vous même de manque de pédagogie
de compréhension est-ce que vous avez
des solutions à proposer
on pourrait mettre en place l'objectif
de l'association puisque c'est vraiment
de rapprocher les citoyens des des
institutions européennes donc pour ça on
a plusieurs programmes le premier c'est
l'europe par les jeunes donc en fait à
partir du cm1 on va dans puisque la
partir du cm1 l'europe est enseignée
dans les écoles primaires
jusqu'en terminale nous allons dans les
établissements scolaires pour justement
un petit peu comme vous on leur a
expliqué le fonctionnement de l'union
européenne mais d'une manière beaucoup
plus ludique et sur la base d'un
discours ou de jeu avec avec les enfants
on a également des des systèmes de
simulation parlement européen pour les
lycéens pour les préparer aux futures
élections européennes et au fait qu'ils
vont devoir voter et s'intéresser à ces
questions là et après on a d'autres
actions de sensibilisation soit des
actions de rue sur des thèmes
particuliers ou des cafés débats ou
voilà pour vraiment sur des thématiques
plus précises pour susciter l'intérêt et
soulever des questions qui sont
printemps primordial dans le débat
public tous les vendent aujourd'hui
philippe le guen vous évoquiez tout à
l'heure de l'éducation à propos de
l'europe
c'est un sujet qui revient parfois dans
l'actualité ce qu'on pourrait imaginer
un cours d'éducation civique
par exemple dès le primaire où dès le
collège c'est ce qu'on fait il ya
institutions françaises pour haquin
comment marche l'état est ce qu'on
pourrait faire la même chose avec la
veyron pourrait au moins va donc
l'europe et dans ses cours
d'institutions de l'éducation civique
que nous avons au niveau français
expliqué l'échelon du dessus qui est le
seul aux européens et comment s'est
articulé par rapport à l'échelon
national ou régional si on ne le fait
pas on s'arrête toujours à comme si bon
une fois qu'on a expliqué les lois
françaises au fonctionnement de la
république ça suffisait mais c'est un
peu mieux d'aller voir un petit peu au
delà nos frontières et puis d'expliquer
que par exemple en allemagne c'est un
pays fédéral en belgique aussi et et de
là on peut expliquer les différences
aussi culturelle et puis apprendre à se
connaître parce que le problème c'est
souvent cette peur que les gens c'est
qu'ils ne se connaissent pas leurs
voisins
d'ailleurs c'est réciproque je veux dire
c'est pas propre à la france vous avez
aussi dans d'autres pays d'aider dès
aujourd'hui des gens qui se demande qui
sont les français qui sont ces défis des
français qui se méfie des uns les autres
or c'est celle inverse que le du projet
qui était à l'origine puisque n'oublions
pas quand même l'origine de ce projet
c'était de de faire la paix durable en
europe et ce qui a été réussi quand
allez vous poser la question est-ce que
c'est pas essentiel aussi de rappeler ce
pourquoi l'europe a été construite et de
faire un rappel historique et de montrer
l'importance initiale de l'europe
écoutez nous nous commençons toujours
par cela parce que nous sommes dans la
maison de jean monnet nous avons la
chance d'être dans la maison de jean
monnet de la basoche dans les yvelines
où jean monnet a conçu le premier texte
que vous citiez tout alors de robert
schuman donc évidemment on commence
toujours par une approche historique on
ne reste pas là dessus mais c'est
important que les jeunes en particulier
sache d'où vient ce projet et puis c'est
important de faire de 2,2 d'injecter un
peu d'émotion dans ce projet parce que
ce qui manque avec l'europe c'est
l'émotion finalement ça nous ça nous
pose ça nous donne aucune émotion
uniquement des lois quoi voilà c'est ça
nous donne aucune émotion or moi je je
suis peut-être un gars mais j'ai une
certaine émotion à me retrouver autour
d'une table avec des amis de d'autres
pays membres de l'union à travailler
avec eux à échanger à faire des projets
ça me fait une certaine émotion je me
dis je préfère ça que si on se tapait
dessus hein donc
effectivement nous nous tapons plus tu
es nous sommes pas forcément d'accord
mais nous discutons et nous recherchons
des compromis c'est bien cela que
devrait signifier le projet pour tout le
monde mais previn rock qu'est ce que
vous répondez à ces solutions qui soient
apportés plus d'éducation plus de
pédagogie aller plus vite plus
rapidement auprès des auprès des plus
jeunes
je pense que toute façon plus plus on
explique et plus
plus on s'approche des des règles de
l'europe etc
c'est tout c'est toujours quelque chose
de bénéfique moi ce que je reproche
c'est que on souhaite
on souhaite maintenir une europe énorme
et on trouve bizarre que les peuples ne
n'adhère pas cela donc mais sans se
poser la question de se dire mais
comment ça se fait il devrait adhérer
ils devraient tous d'accord avec cette
europe là pourquoi on ne les écoute pas
pourquoi pourquoi ils ne se retrouvent
pas alors qu'on veuille qu'on veuille la
paix fin tout le monde souhaite la paix
même si on souhaite une europe peut-être
un peu moins élargie etc
on n'a pas envie de guerre pour autant
on a envie d'une vraie prise en compte
des desiderata des citoyens et moi j'ai
l'impression que dans cette europe là
c'est le citoyen qui est oubliée donc
qui kills qu'il appréhende son comparse
du pays d'à côté ça peut presque se
comprendre parce qu'on se dit mais
finalement à quelle sauce on va être
mangé avec 7,7 europe qui n'en finit pas
de grandir sans prendre en compte nos
inquiétudes à quoi ressemblerait
l'europe selon debout la france est
selon ce lorsque vous pensez vous ce
serait une europe où les pays coopèrent
sur les sujets qu'ils souhaitent selon
leur propre volonté
c'est ça c'est c'est vraiment un gars d
une
et
vraiment garder le libre arbitre des
nations parce que c'est vraiment quelque
chose de très important d'être bien dans
sa nation est justement de s'associer
aux autres c'est c'est pas du tout se
refermer au contraire sauf que sur
certains sujets on ne sera peut-être
plus efficace si on n'est que 6 7 8
plutôt que si on est 28 parce que les
attentes sont tellement divergentes et
le panel est tellement grand que
finalement on n'avance pas dans la bonne
direction
alors les hommes politiques de droite ou
de gauche disent très souvent aussi
qu'il faut revoir l'europe la repenser
on est beaucoup tribune le 9 mai dans
l'est dans les journaux français chacun
à chaque fois ça manières soit par plus
d'europe soit par la mise en place d'un
nouveau plan marshall pour
l'investissement soit pour une europe
tourner vers un noyau resserré de
quelques pays quel est le chantier
prioritaire aujourd'hui selon vous pour
l'europe pour l'europe de demain
philippe le guen si si on devait en
mettre en place un seul chantier lequel
lequel serait-il selon moi je suis assez
d'accord avec ma voisine qu'il faudrait
que ce soit un chantier qui ait de la
visibilité pour les citoyens donc
il ya beaucoup de jus il ya beaucoup de
choses mais dans l'immédiat peut être
contenue delà de l'urgence que nous
avons face au terrorisme etc
moi je serais assez favorable à ce qu'il
y ait réellement alors ça commence il ya
des il ya des premiers projets qui ont
été annoncées par monsieur juncker
président de la commission européenne
mais qu'on est vraiment une police une
coopération policière renforcée et
peut-être même pourquoi pas un fbi à
européen où quelque chose une au moins a
d une meilleure interaction entre les
services parce qu'on voit bien que c'est
une demande de la population quand on
voit que certains terroristes peuvent
traverser les frontières bon et ne
surtout ne sont pas les systèmes ne sont
pas interconnectés entre eux et ça ça
paraît enfin je dirais que sur le plan
commercial et sur le plan des taxes de
d'import-export elles ont été levées je
dirais aujourd'hui vous pouvez depuis
chez vous sur internet commandé quelque
chose et tout est interconnecté mais
alors ce n'est pas interconnectés sur
certains sujets notamment les fichiers
du banditisme ou des délinquants c'est
ça paraît surprenant et ça semble assez
facile à faire quand même ce genre de
choses et je crois que si en effet on
pourrait montrer une coopération
efficace et qui apportent vraiment une
réponse aux citoyens les sites web
après tout c'est ça a du sens mais en
effet je pourrai plus se tourner vers le
citoyen qui tu as peut-être leur
demander leur avis sur un sujet
prioritaire éventuellement bon il faut
se méfier quand même des référendum
parce que ce qui c'est les gens
répondent pas toujours à la question est
souvent ils comprennent pas toujours ce
qui se cache à la question donc mais en
tout cas je pense que sur des sujets qui
touchent les gens une certaine actualité
ça permettrait quand même de répondre à
des préoccupations
voilà mais il ya d'autres sujets mais je
pense que les sujets plus techniques les
gens de même si sa touche leur quotidien
ils ne le voient pas directement
olivier jean rex sur ce chantier
prioritaire cette question là si on
devait mettre en place un chantier au
sein de
l'union européenne c'est pareil je
rejoindrai mais je rejoins mes voisins
sur ce coup-là remettre le citoyen au
coeur de l'europe au coeur de la
construction européenne car quand on
regarde bien dans les médias il ya une
crise il ya encore une crise au niveau
de l'euro il ya une crise migratoire et
compagnie sont encore les états qui
monte ce sont encore les états qui monte
au créneau et qu'il prenne des décisions
or les citoyens sont tout à fait
capables de sont tout à fait capables de
décider en la matière ils ont leur
opinion
alors après on a des tentatives il y a
des il ya des réformes au niveau de la
commission européenne on a des on est en
train de mettre en place des outils
voilà c'est ça avance petit à petit mais
c'est c'est une préoccupation que de
toute façon partage la commission
européenne s'est essayé de refaire
rentrée les citoyens donc je vous refais
un mathilde vidéo votre avis aura
chantier sur la place du citoyen je
pense qu'on va tous partager la même
idée de évidemment leur place est dans
le débat dans le débat public
ce serait peut-être plus de de
coordination donc évidemment au niveau
d'un parquet fédéral mais ça il ya déjà
eu des premières avancées en janvier
notamment mennecier c'est encore très
très limitée et elle a évidemment là la
politique sociale qui est attendu depuis
de très nombreuses années puisque à
l'origine devait enfin le projet
européen et été peint en premier lieu
économique dont nous avait aussi promis
ou du moins annoncer un projet politique
et sociale et ça fait plusieurs dizaines
d'années je pense que je n'étais même
pas né quand les premiers débats avaient
commencé et on est toujours bas sans
véritable projet ni vision sociale
européenne csah en fait le problème de
l'europe c'est qu'on a l'impression que
l'acquis économique ça y est c'est fait
et maintenant on n'arrive pas à se
réinventer a trouvé une nouvelle
nouvelle voie définie rock vous
souhaitiez d'ailleurs réagi le guen a
parlé oui parce que on voit très bien
dans ces échanges que nous avons c'est
que ça a été construit un petit peu à
l'envers je dirais on nous dit oui
l'europe c'est très bien pour la paix et
c'est bien sûr que c'est très bien pour
la paix sauf qu'on n'a pas fait une
europe pour la paix on a fait une comme
une robe de commerce
on n'a pas fait une europe des citoyens
on a fait une europe de commerce
quand on voit que sur sur la zone de
schengen
on a fait tomber les frontières des pays
soit mais on n'a pas mis en place des
corrélations entre les services des
différents pays
on se dit mais comment est-ce possible
et c'est pour ça que tout était prêt
madame s'était rendu à l'amiante et
prive les gouvernements nationaux n'ont
pas souhaité pour le moment le faire
parce qu'il s'était engagés à le faire
c'est bien évidemment il y avait un
corps l'air à tous à tout cela c'est que
si on fait du quelque part du commun il
faut en effet que les mêmes
dispositif s'applique à tout le monde et
c'est quelque part prévu si l'europe ne
marche pas c'est parce que les pays ne
respecte pas le contrat initial on a du
mal à voir cette délégation de
compétence aux fins au sein de l'union
européenne c'est qu'on en demande
beaucoup et on entend beaucoup de
l'union européenne est malheureusement
en compétence exclusive elle en a pas
tant que ça il ya aussi ce problème là
entre le décalage entre attentes et les
moyens réels qu'elle a en sa possession
de drogue tout à fait excuser moi oui il
ya un autre souci on se dit les les
citoyens les peuples se désintéresse de
l'europe
il ya un vrai paradoxe dans l'europe
c'est que on est capable par exemple en
france de faire la coop 21 d'avancé sur
des sujets environnementaux d'une façon
très très intéressante et qui sont
certainement indispensable à notre à
notre avenir est dans le même temps on a
un staff tas dont on n'entend
pratiquement pas parlé
le taf rappelle ce que c'est c'est le
traité transatlantiques entre l'europe
et l'amérique entre les états unis voilà
est en cours de négociation qui est en
cours d semble très mal embarquée malgré
tout qui semble mal embarquée il va pas
être simple mais qui est quand même
quelque chose qui avance dans l'ombre
dont on ne parle pas aux citoyens et qui
est une vraie remise en cause du
commerce international et et surtout de
du libre arbitre des nations et des
règles qu'elles ont posé pour se
protéger va-t-il 2011 pour répondre sur
le taffetas alors que pour la première
chose c'est que ce en cours de
négociation donc c'est aussi compliqué
pour la commission de dévoiler
entièrement le les informations même si
je suis entièrement d'accord sur le fait
que ce n'est pas assez et ni pour les
citoyens ni pour les députés européens
qui eux même s'étonne du peu
d'informations il ya encore après des
garde-fous qui nous protègent contre ce
texte là puisque la décision finale
revient une fois de plus au parlement
européen qui doit voter oui ou non le
texte
et en plus succinct de l'accord mixtes y
aura soit les référendum qui sera
organisé dans des états soit
le vote des parlements nationaux donc il
ya quand même des garde-fous
démocratique qui nous permet de nous
exprimer en tant que la pandémie en
passant d'autres sujets très il ya quand
même quelque chose de très important
c'est qu'il n'ya aucune reprise des
différentes règles c'est pas tellement
le mot que je recherchais qui ont été
prises par rapport à la coop 21 et c'est
alors je comprends pas pourquoi dans un
sens on essaye d'avancer sur
l'environnement etc dans l'autre sens
seat et c'est à cornes
ils n'en tiennent pas compte du tout
document final encore et puis il ya une
commission qui se réunit tous les mois
par la commission rend un rapport tous
les mois devant le parlement repeint
poursuivre si c'est franck discussion
donc on fera une autre émission sur sur
le taffetas je voudrais juste entendre
votre avis sur une interview parue
aujourd'hui sur le site du monde.fr du
député européen belge
excusez moi pour le non guy et
verhofstadt alors voilà verhofstadt
président du groupe centriste au
parlement européen donc ultra pro
européen il dit si l'europe n'est pas
réformé elle disparaîtra est-ce que
c'est sérieux ça comme menace olivier
chinoise est ce que l'europe peut
disparaître
concrètement à court/moyen peut-être
long terme oui tout à fait l'europe
disparaître faut bien comprendre que
l'europe actuellement elle a pas de n'a
pas de direction de cap l'europe on en
fait ce qu'on veut d'ailleurs quand le
président john coeur a été élu
à la tête de la commission européenne
c'est ce qu'il a c'est ce qu'il a dit je
souhaite faire une commission politique
parce que c'est la dernière chance qu'on
a
après si on loupe notre coup c'est on va
dire on va droit dans le mur
donc effectivement l'europe peut
disparaître ça y'a pas de philippe le
mouël
oui il se paraître je sais qu un peu
comme les comme l'extinction de
certaines espèces ça prend ça prend
plusieurs millions d'années un mais en
effet le risque de détricotage d'un
certain nombre de choses est réelle
puisque ce sont les états membres qui
les ont acceptées et si les états
membres décident de ne peut les accepter
ils peuvent alors négocier des des
sorties de certains dispositifs on voit
bien que nos amis britanniques vocal
suivante le tout pour le tout il ya
aussi des personnes qui remettent en
cause les accords de schengen dans
certains pays et qui remettent des
frontières là où il y en avait plus donc
ça le problème c'est que chacun faisant
un petit peu
ce qui veut dans son coin ça ça remet en
cause en effet le projet sur des
décisions qui ont été prises en commun
et qui fonctionnait quand même
relativement bien je suis d'accord que
sur schengen
il ya un problème de contrôle aux
frontières et d'échangé d'informations
alors que la base de données gérad
échange d'informations il est elle est
là mais c'est des gens n'utilisent la
fin de l'été rebiffe ne l'utilisent pas
existe mais c'est pas une raison pour
remettre des barrières je dirais interne
qui vont nuire à la libre circulation
des personnes que nous sommes des
citoyens européens
moi je ne veux pas revivre deux heures
d'attentes pour me rendre en espagne ou
deux heures d'attentes pour travailler
dès traversé la frontière pour aller à
bruxelles
ce que nous avons vécu il ya 25 ans ce
n'est pas possible définir hôtesses que
la disparition de l'europe à terme c'est
ce que vous souhaitez vous en tant que
corps aux sceptiques
ces peines et pas la disparition de
l'europe que l'on souhaite c'est
vraiment une
une autre europe une autre europe
certainement plus restreinte et une une
une cohésion entre certains pays pour
mener à bien certains projets absolument
pas une disparition de l'europe mais pas
une europe comme ça qui ne correspond
pas du tout ni aux intérêts des peuples
parce que là on a on a évoqué certaines
choses mais il ya plein de sujets qui
sont qui sont vraiment inquiétant pour
les
pour pour les différents citoyens des
différents pays et d'ailleurs c'est
vraiment ce que ce que l'on ressent gaïa
vraiment au sein de d'un grand nombre de
pays européens
les peuples ne suivent pas leurs
représentants et il serait peut-être
temps à un moment donné que ses
représentants en prennent conscience
on va justement abordé un dernier point
le braille cité l'actualité la plus
chaude au sein de l'union européenne le
référendum soumis au britannique le 23
juin prochain pour savoir s'ils sont
pour ou contre une sortie de leur pays
de l'union européenne
quel est votre point de vue à vous sur
ce sur ce référendum est ce que c'est
déjà bien de demander leur avis aux gens
et qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez
personnellement même si j'imagine avoir
votre réponse est non mais on est très
partagée au sein de l'association parce
qu'en fait on considère que dans tous
les cas on sera perdant parce que que
les anglais se maintiennent dans l'union
européenne avec l'accord qu'ils ont
négocié avec l'union européenne et
toutes les dérogations qu'ils ont déjà
eu ça affaiblit une fois de plus le
fonctionnement de l'union européenne
et c'est une porte ouverte aussi après
pour que chaque pays négocié dans son
coin de nouvelles dérogations
donc ça voilà on considère que dans tous
les cas on sera perdant et s'ils sortent
évidemment mais c'est un gros frein la
construction européenne et 1 au retour
en arrière qui n'est pas souhaitable
donc voila nous notre rôle c'est juste
d'informer d'essayer de se questionner
sur sur sur ce break site mais voilà on
n'est pas très positif très rapidement
que ce qui nous reste très peu de temps
olivier jeannois qui se vautre votre
avenir vous sur le sujet
si hugh laurie on dit beaucoup que ce
serait un coup fatal porté au projet
européen ce serait finalement le début
de la fin non non non non non
et alors comme 10e comme le disait
monsieur le guen la fin de l'europe ça
peut prendre des millions d'années en la
matière sapho pas ce faux pas
s'inquiéter faut aussi rappeler que
cette possibilité de sortir de l'union
européenne on l'a prévu dans les traités
justement parce que les états nous
disait vous ne respectez vous ne
respectez pas c'est la souveraineté des
états on leur permettait d'entrer dans
l'union européenne comme il le
souhaitait on leur permet aussi de
sortir de l'union européenne comme il le
souhaite donc non on verra ce qu'il
reverra ce qui adviendra les
britanniques son maître au mot en la
matière tout ce que nous on peut faire
au niveau de l'union européenne c'est
leur dire ben voila si vous sortez voilà
ce que voilà ce que vous allez perdre
votre avis à vous en tant que témoin moi
ça me chagrine parce que c'était un
projet politique l'union européenne donc
de voir partir un de nos alliés quand
même
même s'ils n'ont pas été dans l'union
européenne tout de suite enfin dans la
côte dans la construction européenne
c'était des alliés qui ont combattu les
mêmes ennemis à une époque il faut pas
oublier quand même que quelque part on
était main dans la main là pour des
raisons quand même qu'ils sont peut-être
de politique intérieure monsieur cameron
a joué un jeu assez premier ministre oui
à jouer un jeu quand même assez
dangereux
un de faire mais de poser cette question
pour que lui ce soit un plébiscite pour
que puisque l'idée c'est que si les gens
les voeux des anglais vote pour le
maintien dans l'union européenne c'est
lui qui en sortira vainqueur
bon c'est c'est dangereux de jouer
l'europe sur des questions de politique
intérieure me semble-t-il fine rock
votre point de vue à vous
concluait cette émission est ce que vous
souhaitiez par exemple parce que vous
souhaitez que qu'on fasse la même chose
avec la france oui oui parce que moi je
suis partant pour tous pour tous qui est
référendum et la vie des citoyens et je
ne partage pas le point de vue de dire
que les citoyens ne savent pas répondre
selon les questions un référendum je
crois je pense que les gens savent tout
à fait qu'est ce qui est bien pour eux
et donc je pense que le fait de
d'interroger les peuples c'est une bonne
chose
maintenant sur le break ctce je ne sais
pas si c'est vraiment un faire-valoir
pour monsieur cameron ou en tous les cas
une façon de négocier encore des
particularismes
je me pose la question merci à tous les
quatre à avoir participé à cette
émission c'est la fin de ce sept huit
sociétés une émission que vous pouvez
retrouver en podcast sur tv fil 78
points comme bonne soirée à tous